I wasn't able to sign it before I came  but I bought you one of my Pro boards oh  [ __ ] as a little GIF you know what I  mean  which one so what what is this is this  toy machine yeah that's Toy Machine boy  yeah check it out so watch your little  and then like I said man if you  yeah it's air man I'm gonna get you a  box of these regardless  yeah I mean go ahead give me the review  on yeah I mean yeah that's the orange  mango right there that's personally what  my top of my list for my favorites  oh that's gas  hey so we got him  yeah listen hey shock cut the [ __ ]  check I'll hold one of these I'll hold  one of these every episode right here  every [ __ ] episode I'll be a shocking  yeah or you could just have this one but  this is good yeah  I love energy drinks